انعقاد الجلسه بمشاركه من هذا العدد
الكبير من الوزراء رساله واضحه داعمه
لتحرك مجلس الامن الدولي لوقف اطلاق النار
وايصال المساعدات الى غزه
نتنياهو التمسك بحل الدولتين كان موقفا
بارزا هذه المره ومشترك لاكثر من 50 دوله
ومنظمه شاركت في
الاجتماع ان حرمان الشعب الفلسطيني من حقه
في اقامه دوله من شانه ان يطيل الى اجل
غير مسمى هذا الصراع الذي اصبح يشكل
تهديدا كبيرا للسلم والامن الدوليين يجب
ان يعترف الجميع بحق الشعب الفلسطيني في
بناء دولته المستقله بالكامل واي رفض
لقبول حل الدولتين من قبل اي طرف يجب ان
يكون مرفوضا بحزم المطالب تكررت ايضا بشان
ضروره اطلاق تحرك دولي واسع وسريع بشان حل
الدولتين وكجزء من التسويه لما بعد الحرب
في
غزه روسيا حذرت من الاستمرار في التعويل
على واشنطن لوحدها او تاجيل هذا الحل
مجددا نؤكد الطبيعه الراسخه لصيغه
الدولتين لحل الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
من الضروري ان ننفذها في اسرع وقت ممكن
شعرنا بالقلق من تشكيك القياده
الاسرائيليه في هذه الصيغه كما ان
التصريحات الصادره عن وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه حول هذا الموضوع تؤشر الى ان
واشنطن تعور مره اخرى على دبلوماسيتها
الثنائيه التي ترى انها فعاله وهي ليست
كذلك واشنطن ترى في المقابل ان الامر
يتوقف على خيارات صعبه يتعين على
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
اتخاذها لقد سمع الوزير بلينكن مؤخرا من
دول المنطقه استعدادا للمشاركه في اعاده
اعمار غزه اذا كان هناك طريق الى دوله
فلسطينيه اعلم انه قد يكون من الصعب تخيل
ذلك في هذه اللحظه الصعبه لكن قناعه
الرئيس بايدن الراسخه هي ان حل الدولتين
الطريقه الوحيده لانهاء هذا العنف مره
واحده والى
الابد وباستثناء ابقاء القضيه الفلسطينيه
على طاوله الاجتماعات لم يكن هناك اي تحرك
عملي في المجلس منذ بدايه الشهر الجاري
وقد اخفقت محاوله روسيه صينيه لاعتماد
بيانين رئاسيين لوقف اطلاق النار وحل
الدولتين